all right a new five-minute game what's
up later let's go deform and see what is
coming up with huh let's see the old
Indian really our Kings Indian some sort
of old Indian type setup I think ok so I
try to play em xem you like set up with
f3 show a good d 5 yeah I think I want
to close the the center and maybe this
wasn't so great I was a bit worried that
he would move the night and then play
Bishop g5 I wouldn't have had any chance
to prevent that ok so what is this about
I'm wondering about let's check this
briefly c5 protect small tactic here c5
if he takes these six wins apiece but
I'm not threatening anything this is the
problem c5 is a trick if he takes but I
am it it's pretty much pointless if it
doesn't okay some continuum developing
here if it takes on d5 know maybe I
should consider 95 yeah I tried this
this might speed up my my king side
development she takes d5 yeah but f5 now
hmm not sure that i played this so great
okay so why should the night go I think
c3 should be should be normal towards
the the queenside wear my players
usually now him sort of tries to play on
the queenside don't mind that
the sum huh the overall structure is the
environment contagious for me with d5
was 66 so I might like Bishop the ATM I
didn't really pay attention to this ship
the aid would have been would have been
quite interesting flight Ryan bishop b6
here okay so rugby one young to threaten
before the Snider's noticed it's not a
stable peace here it's not can always be
attacked so a 383 queen bee three the
only time we need to kick the Queen ham
should be one Queen a form yeah
let's see do I have something better
here
the question is what about BP 3v3 Queen
Queen moves to a six and then before
this is all a bit shaky for what okay
but I try it I try okay guy Queen d3
yeah maybe didn't really look at this
move at all hmm ok it's not done it's
not terrible or anything for me maybe be
form yeah before then you need to learn
young exchange queens and then the snide
why should the night go 93 I have
push-up see to Bishop situ
I want to take on f5 if possible hmm it
takes on if I might need to recapture
with palm yeah well I might need to some
nicely put any two is threatening Bishop
the 8-ounce awesome I need to get going
here aha surprise so this is you want to
take on d5 on pileup on the FL I'm not
sure don't really understand what's
going on to be honest thought you would
just take on your form with no problems
ah simple tactic I overlooked a simple
tactic here okay mmm this is not good to
put it down to put it mildly yeah just
lost now also considering the time
situation
when the position is also i'm just-just
a rack here maybe yeah I'm always trying
to be optimistic but hard too hard to
believe here why should should be just
lost here a 3 is also gone this is some
problem it cannot really enter on the C
file this d4 Knight is just a terrible
piece to to play against
f
yeah go to Bishop you one even yeah it
should be one or the smooth
yeah I'm just a piece down just a piece
down yeah this was really a bad game
that game by me
yeah I'm not quite sure this shouldn't
be so terrible but maybe I'm here before
was was mistimed it's not a great
position for white anyway yeah but
shouldn't be a shouldn't be really worse
yeah I simply didn't take this rook
chief rooks III into account the C file
is of course a weakness hem and this
Bishop da to be six is a problem yeah
I'm not not very coordinated TM this
wasn't wasn't so great I mean this kind
of position shouldn't be it shouldn't be
worse for wide of course all right so
just a bad game and let's hope it gets
better next one